hey an Indiana man is behind bars after
a carjacking high-speed chase and an
officer-involved shooting
let's go out let's go out
go touch the gun hands out
hand out
the incident began at about 4 pm on
March 29th that's when Indianapolis
dispatch received a 9-1-1 call for a
carjacking I'm at Georgetown and 56th
Street there's a front-end collision and
a carjacking that happened here a man
crashed into me he hit another car and
headed into these days and jumped out
and carjacked a woman security camera
footage shows a vehicle driven by 33
year old Michael Barnes run a red light
on the city's Northwest side a vehicle
with the right-of-way crashes into barns
before his vehicle crashes into another
vehicle seconds later Barnes climbs
through the passenger side of his
stalled vehicle and approaches a nearby
vehicle with a gun Barnes allows the
woman to take a child out of the back
seat before driving off with her car
what's the vehicle
this lady's car was carjacked what's the
vehicle 2014 Chevy Impala it's a 2014
dark gray Chevy Impala which way did it
go
[Music]
last scene going northbound does it have
any damage to it no my car
[Music]
body camera video shows an Indianapolis
Police Officer arrive on the scene
speaking with a carjacking victim did he
have a gun or anything
out the car but he walked up to me with
the gun he was tired
what do you look like
mail it's gonna be a confirmed
carjacking within minutes ipd officials
locate the stolen vehicle they attempt
to pull barns over but he runs multiple
red lights speeding upwards of 80 miles
per hour officials finally catch up with
Barnes when he stops his vehicle on an
interstate on-ramp
immediately two separate officers opened
fire on barns after he points a gun at
them
zoomed in body camera footage shows
Barnes pulling the weapon before
officers opened fire a passerby also
caught the incident on a dash cam
recording showing Barnes pull out a
weapon first body camera video shows
what happens next after two officers
fire their weapons
hey guys I'm gonna get a long gun out
okay
tell is that somebody good for business
hey
[Music]
guys he's got his hands up I'm gonna be
Stewart come with me out let's go out
let's go out
go touch the gun hands out
hands out
get someone with gloves come out with me
hands down investigators found a handgun
laying on the ground next to Barnes as
they approached they then gave Barnes
medical attention before paramedics
arrived he was taken to the hospital
where he survived his injuries
Barnes now faces multiple charges
including pointing a firearm at another
and resisting law enforcement the
officer involved shooting is still under
investigation at this time reporting for
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie